اما اعداد الجرحى هناك 3,500 جريحه هؤلاء
تم قيدهم في السجلات المشافي والنقاط
الطبيه والعيادات المتنقله لكن عدد الجرحى
يكون اكبر من ذلك لان المشاكل لم تستطع
استقبال المزيد منه وبالتالي لم يتم
تسجيلهم اضافه الى عدد كبير من المصابين
والجرحى قاموا بمداوله انفسهم ذاتيا خارج
المشافي والنقاط الطبيه
المتخصصه من الاخبار الجيده ايضا بان
اعداد الناجين اعداد الذين تم انتشالهم من
تحت الارقام على كامل الجغرافيا السوريه
بلغ حوالي 520 حتى الان بجمع احصائيتي
النظام ومناطق المعارضه وهو عدد ارتفع
بحوالي 100 وثلاثه اشخاص عما كان عليه يوم
امس بما يعني ان الجهود يعني ازاله
الانقاض واخراج الاحياء من تحت هذه
الانقاذ تكللت بنجاح مقبول نتحدث عن اشخاص
خلال يعني بضع ساعات رغم انه يعني
العمليات كانت تتم في الليل وكان هناك
صعوبه في الوصول الى هؤلاء الاسيمه في ظل
يعني ضعف الامكانيات ضعف المعدات وايضا
ضعف الخبره في الوصول اليهم المباني
المنهاره حتى الان عادل يعني عددها وصل
الى حوالي 300 مبنى منهار بالكامل
يتقاسم مناطق النظام والمعارضه العدد 550
لكن هناك الالاف من المباني المتضرره التي
تشهد شقوق وتصدعات والتي يطلب منها
الاهالي من قبل الجهات المتخصصه بعدم
العوده اليها خوفا من حدوث ايه هزات
ارتداديه لربما تؤدي الى سقوط هذه المنازل
فوق
السكان في حاله وعادوا الى هذه المنازل
وهذا يفسر العدد الكبير من الناس الذين
بقوا حتى الخارج هذه المدن الاربعه
الرئيسيه شمال غرب سوريا وايضا مناطق
الساحل والداخل السوريه